we had VHS as I remember big you know we
had to ride our bike to go get it and
they had that porn room remember the
room sure yeah I worked at a video store
oh you did when I was a kid when I was
in high school wow so I got a little
overly too quickly exposed like I mean
we had a porn room oh and I would run
the guy that around on the store was
just he just gave me the keys like he
made me run the store oh my God so yeah
after I would wait I was like look at
the clock waiting for it like
I just wanted to close so I could go in
the back room in his office and just
[__] just jizz everywhere I would
have [__] licked the boxes I think
yeah it was real it was a lot oh I
remember seeing some but one guy
chiseled some tits into a [__] tree
in our neighborhood right like in these
woods behind our fence
and see what had chiseled a [__]
setup oh the hangers homie some [__]
milk muffins Daddy he [__] chiseled a
pair you mean like an artist like he he
yeah or like a I don't know what it's
called what's that chisel with a little
flat head on it
yeah I don't know what his tools were or
whatever but this guy was pretty good I
would say probably
and then but people would go out there
and come you know no [__] oh you'd see
there was porn magazines back there and
it was on this little Hill kind of so it
almost had this that's incredible native
or think people I think people said it
was Native American or something but I
don't know but you didn't you knew the
guy that did it though oh yeah
oh yeah amazing dude I'll tell you
another story about the same guy so
he one time me and my buddy this kid's
Summerall were walking on the street and
it but it was a tree though so it was
like a living tree yeah and there was
tits on it that he chiseled and not I
mean if folks would come and jack off to
it yeah I don't know how many folks yeah
I mean it wasn't like people were like
buses yeah it wasn't like yeah what do
you call it but a Graceland or something
yeah
but if you knew you knew you know what
I'm saying work
um and this was also woods and people
used to go to the woods to jerk off huh
and that was something you'd find I
think in any town you hear people
there's pornography in the woods it used
to be yeah people would bury a stack of
Duty I found a stack of porn that's in
the woods that was first thing I first
time I ever saw any of that yeah and we
had they had an empty broken washing
machine right there and people would put
the porn in there right and so uh you
get to you know get your [__] you know
get that deal out and then now the first
porn I ever jerked off to was some girl
or tits in shorts and she had gravel all
over it because because I found in the
dirt oh yeah that magic just like pock
marks from the gravel
life is sad buddy yeah but it's real
dude God and look In some cultures you
still find that you know so go ahead I
don't mean interrupt you so what no that
was it that would be you know you would
ejaculate to that and uh but it was a
different yeah people would go into the
woods it's almost like
you know you'd Bring It Back To Nature
I mean my dad I remember caught us
jerking off one time he made us bury it
in the yard bury the semen in the yard
well to make it like
um
respectful or something yeah
but you would just you wait a minute how
did he he caught wait first he said he
caught us jerking off yeah yeah well I
guess it was there was uh it was just me
but I say us I don't feel alone I think
I do that a lot sure that makes sense
but so he walked in and you would you
would just come on yourself yeah well my
mother caught me
and then she so she went to him and said
he's been jerking off she told him yeah
she would always kind of rat me out
about stuff like yeah but was the jizz
doesn't stay like how did he no but he
just said wherever this is you need to
take it and put it in the yard and that
was it so he just kind of went like that
and no it was on a sheet oh it was on a
sheet okay so the thing you came on yeah
had to be buried
it made me created respect for him I
think like as a and it gave me a kind of
a
uh affinity for nature
sure you [__] nature in a sense
oh dude I remember my buddy would come
over and we would just [__] Mount our
pillows in the car yeah different
corners of the room yeah when your
teenage or preteen boys when they start
pre-teen yeah there is there is like uh
camaraderie in that stuff yeah I had a
friend who used to we used to tell each
other stories about girls like I I'd
sleep over his house and he'd sleep on
his bed I'd sleep on the floor and we
called it telling each other juicers
that's what we called it juicer so like
he would tell me he'd say you know pick
a girl and I'd say you know Gretchen
yeah and he'd say okay so you you and
Gretchen are in school and you know
you're like you decide to walk home
together and go to her house and he just
walk me through this story
for us good and then I do it for him
with whatever girl he wanted oh I can't
even imagine y'all did that for each
other yeah we did it was yeah and I
don't think
that's awesome I don't know if we were
coming yet
I think it was just about squeezing it
and getting this like getting this
feeling and just listening to what he's
saying and just it didn't occur to us
that I mean we're talking about girls we
didn't feel weird about it we we were
good friends you know I I liked him he
was a good kid and it sounds like it
yeah he was you know it's something you
do for a buddy dude if I laid on a bunk
bed right now and another man laid on
the floor and told me uh took me through
like a good story I'd probably
appreciate it
it's so much more real than having to
just jerk off to something you see on a
screen yeah that's no good I think
that's one of the things right yeah I
think
dude I remember when I first got an
erection I thought it was poop coming
out of the whoa front
and I remember being so scared
and um and I told this teacher and
I then I think the teacher might have
been like a gay man and so then I got
this totally weird reaction from him
but I remember thinking that poop was
coming out of my
like getting gotten lost whoa and that's
what the erection was that's a
terrifying thought oh dude
because then I was afraid to go pee
because I was like it's gonna smell bad
oh my God and that's terrifying oh
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one